OPENED..
AND IT IS QUITE THE PLACE TO
SEE..
THANKS FOR JOINING OUR
SPECIAL-- DESTINATION VEGAS.
I'M CHRISTIAN CAZARES.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
AND I'M KIRSTEN JOYCE.
THE RESORT IS JUST A FEW OF THE
MANY EXCITING THINGS HAPPENING
AS LAS VEGAS EMERGES OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC.
OVER THE NEXT HALF OUR--WE'LL
SHARE THE PLACES THAT ARE
HELPING LAS VEGAS BECOME A TOP
TRAVEL
DESTINATION.
WITH ACTIVITIES NOT ONLY FOR
TOURISTS-- BUT LOCALS TOO.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
IT'S A LAS VEGAS SPOT NOT MANY
PEOPLE KNOW OF...YET.
"MUSEUM OF SELFIES" OPENED IT'S
DOORS JUST A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO.
HERE'S A LOOK INSIDE THIS TRENDY
VENUE THAT YOU'LL WANT TO ADD TO
YOUR 'DESTINATION' LIST.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
HEY GUYS WE ARE INSIDE
THE MUSEUM OF SELFIES.
IT'S A BRAND NEW VENUE ON THE
LAS VEGAS STRIP THAT WILL FORCE
YOUR IMAGINATION TO GO WILD.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>> FROM GIANT EDIBLE BITES TO A
SELFIE STICK-MADE THRONE.
THE MUSEUM OF SELFIES IN LAS
VEGAS IS GETTING MORE THAN LIKES
FROM VISITORS.
((COREY YOUNG - TEXAS
TOURIST
WE FEEL LIKE A KID.
I
FEEL LIKE A KID ALL OVER AGAIN))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>> THE VENUE LOCATED ALONG THE
LINQ PROMENADE RECENTLY LAUNCHED
AS THE SECOND IN IT'S FRANCHISE,
BUT ACCORDING TO IT'S CREATOR
IT'S ONE OF A KIND.
((KATE KUTEPOVA-
OWNER - MUSEUM OF SELFIES OUR
MUSEUM IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
WE DID HAVE TRADITIONAL MUSEUM
WHERE YOU CAN GO AND SEE STUFF
AND TOUCH THINGS AND PLAY WITH
THEM.
WE DECIDED THAT WE HAVE TO
CREATE SOMETHING DIFFERENT
WITH THAT.
))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>> YOU CAN SNAP A PICTURE IN
THIS
LAVISH JET WHILE PRETENDING TO
DRINK CHAMPAGNE AS YOU FLY INTO
LAS VEGAS OR DO SEVERAL CLICKS
ON YOUR CAMERA PHONE WHILE
BATHING IN THIS ROYAL TUB FILLED
WITH GOLD COINS.
ONE OF MY FAVORITES---THIS
FLIPPED BEDROOM.
((KATE KUTEPOVA-
OWNER - MUSEUM OF SELFIES
KEEP YOUR HAND IN THE
MIDDLE.
MOVE YOUR LEG LIKE THIS
1-2-3 PERFECT
WE WILL EDIT THIS
PICTURE
HANDSTAND.
HOW COOL
IS THAT ))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>>THE MUSEUM ALSO CLAIMS TO
HAVE THE FIRST SELFIE EVER TAKEN
AND DOCUMENTED.
((KATE KUTEPOVA-
OWNER - MUSEUM OF SELFIES WE
HAVE A LOT OF
ARTIFACTS LIKE BACK IN 1835 THAT
SHOW THE VERY FIRST SELFIE THAT
WAS TAKEN THE SAME WAY THAT WE
TAKE THEM RIGHT NOW.
ROBERT CORNELIUS DID IT WITH A
MIRROR IN
FRONT WITH A BIG MIRROR IN FRONT
AND
HE SNAPPED A SELFIE THE SAME WAY
WE DO
RIGHT NOW.))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>>> SUMMER HAS OFFICIALLY
BEGUN
AND THAT MEANS YOU MAY BE
LOOKING FOR A SPOT TO JUST HANG
OUT AT CHILL.
ICE BAR AT THE LINQ PROMENADE
HAS GOT YOU COVERED! IT JUST
UNDERWENT RENOVATIONS AND
REOPENED WITH A WHOLE NEW LOOK
OWNER NOEL BOWMAN SAYS IT'S
A FUN EXPERIENCE FOR THE WHOLE
FAMILY.
((NOEL BOWMAN, OWNER,
ICE BAR LINQ
THE KIDS LOVE TO COME
OUT IN THE SUMMERTIME, WE GET
FAMILIES OF ALL KINDS INSIDE.
I WISH WE COULD DO SNOWBALL
FIGHTS INSIDE, UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S NOT THE CASE BUT IT SURE
IS FUN TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
WITH THIS WEATHER TO
HAVE SOME FUN))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>>> BOWMAN SAYS THE MOST
ENJOYABLE PART IS CREATING A
WINTER WONDERLAND IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE MOJAVE DESERT.
AND THE BEST PART, GUESTS MAY
NEVER HAVE THE SAME EXPERIENCE
TWICE!
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
DID YOU KNOW THAT LAS VEGAS IS
HOME TO THE WORLD'S LARGEST
OBSERVATION WHEEL? THE HIGH
ROLLER AT THE LINQ STANDS AT 550
FEET HIGH WHICH IS A FULL 107
FEET HIGHER THAN THE
LONDON EYE!
EACH RIDE ON THE HIGH ROLLER
LASTS 30 MINUTES AND OFFERS SOME
PRETTY INCREDIBLE PANORAMIC
VIEWS
OF THE STRIP SO IT'S DEFINITELY
ONE OF THE BEST INSTAGRAM SPOTS
IN LAS VEGAS.
THE BEST TIME TO GO ON THE HIGH
ROLLER IS AT NIGHT.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>> WHILE MANY ARE USED TO THE
LAS VEGAS CITY LIGHTS, SHOWS
AND AMAZING FOOD THE WALDORF
ASTORIA IS THE FIRST HOTEL TO
BRING A CLASSIC BUT ELEGANT
EXPERIENCE.
LOCATED ON THE STYLISH 23RD
FLOOR YOU WILL FIND THIS TEA
LOUNGE A MEMORABLE ONE.
(( CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"TEA IS JUST GOING TO
GET MORE ATTRACTION )) ((
CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"THIS SPACE REALLY
LETS YOU EXPERIENCE VEGAS FROM
AND EAGLELISED STAND POINT ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>CHINTAN DADHICH IS
WALDORF ASTORIA'S GENERAL
MANAGER.
HE SAYS TEA SERVICE
STARTED 10 YEARS AGO..
PROVIDING A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE.
(( CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"WHEN YOU COME TO
VEGAS AND YOU THINK OF LAS VEGAS
AFTERNOON TEA IS NOT THE FIRST
THING THAT COMES TO MIND ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>BUT THIS ELEGANT
AFTERNOON TEA AND AMAZING
VIEW--HAS BEEN A POPULAR
ATTRACTION FOR NOT JUST
TOURISTS, BUT LOCALS TOO.
((CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"WE START WITH A RAY
OF TEAS THAT ARE OFFERED TO YOU
)) ((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>MULTIPLE INFUSIONS,
MULTIPLE FLAVORS AND TEA
EXPERTS, TAKE YOU THROUGH THE
MENU.
(( CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"NEXT COMES THE
CULINARY DELIGHTS THAT ARE THEN
PAIRED WITH YOUR TEA SERVICE ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>FROM OOLONG TEA TO FLOWERY
EARL GRAY AND EVEN CHERRY
BLOSSOM YOU WILL FIND YOURSELF
FINDING TRANQUILITY IN A CUP OF
TEA.
(( CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"THAT ACTUALLY COMES
WITH CULINARY DELIGHTS SUCH AS
MACAROONS THAT ARE PAIRED
PERFECTLY WITH THEM THERE IS TEA
SANDWICHES WHICH ARE DECADENT ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE
PERFECT PHOTO OPPORTUNITY THIS
TEA LOUNGE HAS YOU COVERED.
((CHINTAN DADHICH-
GENERAL MANAGER WALDORF ASTORIA
"RIGHT FROM THE TIME
YOU GET TO THE HOTEL FROM OUR
FRONT DRIVE TO THE GOLD WALL ON
THE 23RD LEVEL AND THIS BEATIFUL
VIEW HERE IN TEA LOUNGE AS WELL
AS THE SKYBAR NEXT TO IT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY INSTAGRAM FRIENDLY ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>EVEN ADDING A UNIQUE VENDING
MACHINE FOR SOME BUBBLY.
SALLY JARAMILLO REPORTING ON THE
LAS VEGAS STRIP.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
THIS EXPERIENCE WELCOMES ALL
AGES...
PRICES ARE 58 DOLLARS FOR ADULTS
AND
30 FOR KIDS
RESERVATIONS ARE RECOMMENDED 3
TO 4 WEEKS IN ADVANCE.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>>BABY BIRDS CAFE LOCATED NEAR
SAHARA AND DURANGO HAS BEEN IN
THE BUSINESS NOW FOR 3 YEARS
AND IT'S BRINGING MORE THAN
COFFEE TO THE LAS VEGAS VALLEY.
IT'S THE LAS VEGAS DESERT BUT
WHEN YOU COME IN HERE IT FEELS
LIKE YOUR RELAXING BACK YARD.
SUPAKULLAYA PANNOK IS BABY
BIRD'S CAFE OWNER SHE SAYS AFTER
TRAVELING AROUND THE GLOBE SHE
DISCOVERED A LOVE FOR VISITING
CUTE CAFES.
SINCE LAS VEGAS IS THE
ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD SHE WANTED TO BRING
SOMETHING
CUTE, CLASSY AND HEALTHY.
FROM COFFEE TO SMOOTHIES, TEA
HEALTHY TOAST AND EVEN ACAI
BOWLS.
VEGAN AND GLUTEN FREE OPTIONS
ARE ALSO A PLUS HERE.
(( SUPAKULLAYA
PANNOK - BABY BIRDS CAFE
"WHEN THE MOTHER
FEED THE BABY BIRD IT'S GOTTA BE
GOOD THING RIGHT AND HEALTHY
LIKE YOU EAT SOMETHING GOOD AND
MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU CAN FLY LIKE BABY BIRD BUT
ALSO I THINK ABOUT NATURE ))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>> ASIDE FROM THE DELICIOUS AND
PRETY FOOD ITEMS YOU CAN FIND
HERE
IT IS ALSO INSTAGRAM FRIENDLY
THANKS TO THEIR FLOWER WALL,
MOUNTAIN AND LAKE VIEWS.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
A BORN AND RAISED LAS VEGAS
CONCEPT FOUNDED IT IN 2010.
FUKU BURGER STARTED AS A
RESTAURANT BUT IT FAILED BECAUSE
OF THE ECONOMY...
IT WAS THEN REVAMPED AS A
FOOD TRUCK.
IT'S AN "ALL AMERICAN" BURGER
WITH A JAPANESSE TWIST.
FUKU MEANS LUCK A TERM SHARED BY
JAPANESSE AND CHINESE ASIDE FROM
THEIR DISTINCTIVE AND VERY
DELICIOUS BURGER MENU YOU CAN
FIND ART WORK THAT
INVLOVES
JAPANESSE TOYS AND ANAMEI
ALONG WITH
80'S 90'S RETRO PRINTS.
FUKU BURGER OWNER COLIN FUKUNAGA
SAYS
WHETHER YOU'RE A FOODIE OR
INSTAGRAM BLOGGER THIS IS THE
PLACE FOR YOU.
((COLIN FUKUNAGA-
FUKU BURGER OWNER
"THE MOST POPULAR
FROM THE FOODIE STANDPOINT
COMING TO US TO TRY SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAN A REGULAR BURGER
IS A NUMBER 2 WHICH IS A TOMAGO
BURGER WHICH MENAS EGG IN
JAPANESSE
FRIED EGG OVER CRISPY
ONIONS FOODACOCKY SEASON WITH A
HOMEMADE TERRIYAKI SAUCE ))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
FUKUNAGA SAYS THEY ARE NOT
INVENTING THE WHEEL- THEY ARE
JUST MIXING AND MATCHING SWEAT
AND SAVORY INGREDIENTS.
ALSO SHOWCASING THE ABILITIES OF
WHAT LOCALS CAN DO IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL CITY.///
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
NEXT ON DESTINATION
VEGAS
WE TAKE YOU TO OUTDOOR DINING ON
THE LAS VEGAS STRIP.
A LOOK INSIDE BEER PARK IS
COMING UP.
((SALLY JARAMILLO// A
HIDDEN OASIS IN THE SOUTHERN
HIGHLANDS AREA..
WHY MANY ARE SAYING BECCA'S
RESTAURANT AND LOUNGE IS THE
PLACE TO BE.///))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST UNIQUE
SPOTS IN LAS VEGAS TO GRAB A
BEER.
PICTURE THIS -
TAKING A SIP OUT ON A PATIO
OVERLOOKING THE BELLAGIO
FOUNTAINS.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
IT REALLY DOESNT GET ANY BETTER
THAN THAT.
HERE'S MORE ON THIS
"DESTINATION" THAT PROMISES TO
BE A ONE OF KIND EXPERIENCE.
((SONIA OMANA - CA
TOURIST
I HAVENT TRIED THIS
ONE ACTUALLY --GOOD!))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>>GREAT VIEWS AND GREAT
BREWS...
HERE AT THE
"BEER PARK" AT THE PARIS.
((SONIA OMANA - CA
TOURIST
ITS GREAT ITS OUR FIRST
TIME.
WE ARE ABOUT TO TRY THE BURGER
AND NACHOS.
IT ALL LOOKS REALLY GOOD.))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>> THE 19 THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT SECOND-LEVEL SPOT OPENED IN
2016 BUT IT'S POURING MUCH MORE
THAN BEER, POST PANDEMIC.
((JASON ELLEFSON -
DIRECTOR, BEER PARK
WE ARE ALL ABOUT
EXPERIENCE HERE.
IF YOU HAVE A GREAT EXPERIENCE
HERE DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
PLACE ON THE STRIP I THINK WE'VE
WON.))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>>
THE NAME ITSELF ATTRACTS
THOUSANDS TO EXPLORE IT'S
VARIETY OF BEERS BUT THE FOOD
ACCORDING TO THIS GROUP...
((ANGELICA DIAZ -
TOURIST
WE GOT THE GRILLED
CHEESE AND THE CHICKEN STEAK
(TAKES BITE) AMAZING))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>> WITH MISTERS AND FANS TO COOL
YOU OFF...
THIS TRENDY VENUE IS FILLED WITH
GIANT TVS AND EVEN HAS AN INDOOR
LOUNGE WITH A VARIETY OF GAMES.
JUST A SAMPLE OF WHY THEY WERE
VOTED "BEST ROOFTOP BAR" BY
THRILLIST.
((ANGELICA DIAZ -
TOURIST
I THINK ITS GREAT I
HAVENT SEEN THE WATER SHOW IN SO
LONG AND WHEN IT CAME ON I DIDNT
REALIZE WE WERE
SO CLOSE TO THE FOUNTAINS.
THAT WAS A GREAT SURPRISE))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
THE "BEER PARK" DIRECTOR TELLS
ME DURING THE DAY THE VENUE IS
GEARED TOWARDS FAMILIES BUT AT
NIGHT THE ENERGY IS STRONGER.
GOT TO ADD IT TO YOUR LIST TO
CHECKOUT.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>> LAS VEGAS, KNOWN FOR
BEING THE ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD AND NOW ALSO AS ONE
OF THE MOST INSTAGRAMABLE
PLACES.
FROM COLORFUL DISHES TO
BEAUTIFUL SCENERY.
SALLY JARAMILLO SHOWS US A ONE
OF A KIND PERSPECTIVE.
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
BECCA IS KIND OF OUR
HIDDEN LITTLE SECRET HERE IN
SOUTHERN HIGHLANDS ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>YOU CAN FIND THIS GEM AT THE
TUSCAN HIGHLANDS APARTMENT
COMMUNITY.
STEVEN KENNEDY IS THE MANAGING
PARTNER..
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"IT'S A AMERICAN
ITALIAN SPORTS BAR WITH ABOUT 34
TELEVISIONS TO WATCH GAMES FULL
BAR LIQUOR BEER DRAFT BEER WINE
)) ((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>> AND IT ALSO HAS A 10 THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT PATIO.
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"LOTS OF AMENTIES
HERE FOR THE COMMUNITY TO COME
OUT AND ENJOY INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
DINNING ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>> KENNEDY AND HIS TEAM WANTED
TO CREATE A COMMUNITY INSIDE A
COMPLEX WITH AN ATMOSPHERE THAT
WILL MAKE YOU KEEP COMING BACK.
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"WE HAVE A WINE
GARDEN THAT HAS ABOUT 40 TABLES
WE HAVE A CUSTOM WINE CART THAT
WE BUILT AND BROUGHT FROM TUSCAN
ITALY )) ((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"WE HOST EVENTS OUT
THERE ON THE WEEKENDS WITH SOME
CHARCUTER AND WINE AND DIFFERENT
SPECIALTY COCKTAILS ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>EVEN MUSIC..
BECCA'S IS FAMILY FRIENDLY..
AND IS ATTRACTING TOURISTS.
(( STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"THE LA COMMUNITY
PEOPLE ARE DEFIENTLY POPPING IN
AND CATCHING US ON THE WAY IN
AND ON THE WAY OUT ))
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"WE CREATED THIS
RESORT STYLE ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>> BRINGING A UNIQUE DESTINATION
TO LAS VEGAS.
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"BEAUTIFUL PATIO VIEWS
, FIRE PITS WE HAVE A GARDEN
WALL WITH THE INSTAGRAM PHOTO
OPPORTUNITY WE GOT HAND
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>> BUT IT DOESN'T STOP THERE...
((STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S
RESTAURANT
"IN THE EVENING THE
SUN SETS OVER THE MOUNTAINS HERE
IT'S BEAUTIFUL ))
(( STEVEN
KENNEDY-MANAGING PARTNER AT
BECCA'S RESTAURANT
"SOME GREAT PHOT OPS
SO COME DOWN AND GET THAT
INSTAGRAM PICTURE ))
((SALLY JARAMILL) >> SALLY JARAG
OM LAS VEGAS.
KIRSTENOYCE)) BECCA'S RESTAURAN
KNOWN FOR THEIR BRUNCH IS ON
SUNDAYS.. FROM 11-1.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
WE'RE NOT DONE YET-- WE HAVE
MORE COMING UP ON DESTINATION
VEGAS.
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"IT'S JUST A WONDERFUL
WONDERFUL PICTURE ))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
HOW FLYING OVER THE AIR HAS
TRULY TAKEN MOMENTUM IN THE TOWN
OF PAHRUMP.
WHY MANY ARE CALLING THIS THE
PERFECT KODAK MOMENT.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>> IF YOU WANT TO EXPERIENCE THE
ADVENTURE OF A LIFETIME, AND SEE
NEVADA LIKE NEVER BEFORE...
THEN THIS IS YOUR CHANCE.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
A HOT AIR BALLOON RIDE WILL
GIVE YOU SPECTACULAR 360 VIEWS
OF PAHRUMP AND THE MOUNTAINS..
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"SEEMS LIKE EVERY
YEAR WE WERE MOVING A LITTLE BIT
FATHER OUT A LITTLE BIT FARTHER
OUT BECAUSE
OF THE GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THE
CITY ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>DOUG CAMPBELL OWNS LAS VEGAS
BALLOON RISES AND BALLOONS OVER
PAHRUMP.
HE HAS BEEN IN THE HOT AIR
BALLOON BIZ FOR 53 YEARS.
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
WE KINDA DISCOVERED
PAHRUMP AS FAR AS FLYING ))
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"PAHRUMP IS VERY
RURAL IT'S VERY WIDE OPEN ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>THOSE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THIS CALL IT MAGICAL.
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"BALLON RIDES HAVE
BEEN REFERRED TO AS PEACEFUL ,
TRANQUIL , THERAPEUTIC, ROMANTIC
IT ALL DEPENDS WHAT KIND OF MOOD
YOU'RE IN )) ((SALLY
JARAMILLO))
>>SO HOW DOES THIS ADVENTURE
WORK?
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"DEPENDING OF THE TIME
OF YEAR WE ARE MEETING ANYWHERE
FROM 5-7 ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>FLYING FIRST THING IN THE
MORNING IS USUALLY THE COOLEST,
CALMEST AND SAFEST.
TO INFLATE A BALLOON, THE WAIT
IS 15-20 MINUTES.
((DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"ONCE THE BALLOON
STANDS UP WE PUT OUR GUEST IN
THE BASKET THEN WE TAKE OFF FOR
ABOUT 45 MINUTES TO AN HOUR ))
(( DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"WE LOOK AT THE WEST
BASIN SIDE OF MT.CHARLESTON AND
CALIFORNIA BORDER IS ONLY ABOUT
4 MILES THE WEST OF US ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>>THERE ARE ALSO SEVERAL PHOTO
OPPORTUNITES TO SHARE WITH
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
(( DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"THE BEST ONE IS ONCE
WE GET OUT GUEST IN THE BASKET
WITH US WE HAVE THEM TURN THEIR
CELL PHONE ON SELFIE MODE AND
HOLD IT DOWN ABOUT WAIST HIGH
AND HAVE THE PEOPLE IN THEIR
PARTY OVERLOOK DOWN INTO IT ))
(( DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"YOU'RE LITERALLY
FLOATING A THOUSAND 2 THOUSAND
FEET IN THE AIR ))
(( DOUG CAMPBELL- LAS
VEGAS BALLOON RIDES AND BALLOONS
OVER PAHRUMP OWNER
"YOU'RE LOOKING OUT
ALL OVER GOD'S CREATION ))
((SALLY JARAMILLO))
>> SALLY JARAMILLO
REPORTING FROM PAHRUMP.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
THE BALLOON RIDES ARE A
SHARED BASKET-- THE COST-- 275
PER PERSON.
PAHRUMP OR LAS VEGAS LOCALS GET
A 50 DOLLAR DISCOUNT.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
NEXT ON DESTINATION VEGAS.
A CYCLE DOWN....TRAIN
TRACKS.
HOW YOU CAN PARTICIPATE IN RAIL
EXPLORERS AT ANY PART OF THE
DAY.
((SALLY JARAMILLO
ONLY 45 MINUTES AWAY
FROM LAS VEGAS, PAHRUMP IS
BECOMING THE NEW TUSCANY .
COMING UP I'LL TELL
YOU HOW YOU CAN WINE UP.///))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>>> "RAIL EXPLORERS" IN
BOULDER CITY HAS ROLLED OUT ITS
SUMMER PROGRAM, AND IT'S TAKING
OUR HOT DESERT WEATHER INTO
ACCOUNT.
((DIVISION MANAGER
HEATHER ABEL/RAIL EXPLORERS LAS
VEGAS: WE'RE GOING TO DO A 6:30
AM SUNRISE WITH MIMOSAS, WE'RE
GOING TO DO A SUPER SOAKER RIDE
AT IN THE MORNING, A WATER GUN
FIGHT BETWEEN OUR STAFF AND THE
RIDERS, THAT'S GOING TO BE FUN,
THEN WE CLOSE FOR THEY DAY AND
OPEN BACK UP FOR AN 8 PM
TWILIGHT RIDE, AND IT'S NOT
VEGAS WITHOUT
OUR NEON...
WE'VE GOT OUR BIKES ALL LIT UP
WITH NEON, SO WE'VE GOT THAT
GOING ON
TWICE A NIGHT.
))
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
THEY OFFER TEN PERCENT DISCOUNT
FOR NEVADA RESIDENTS.
AND ARE LAUNCHING A PROMOTION IN
COORDINATION WITH "FOX'S
BARBECUE IN BOULDER CITY".//
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>> IF YOU'RE A FIRST TME VISITOR
TO PAHRUMP ...
THE FIRST THING YOU'LL NOTICE, A
VERY SCENIC ROAD..
HIGHWAY 160...
IT IS ALSO THE SHORTEST ROUTE
BETWEEN LAS VEGAS AND DEATH
VALLEY..
AND AS SALLY JARAMILLO REPORTS..
IT IS GETTING NOTICED FOR
SOMETHING ELSE.
((JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO HERE IN OUR TOWN
TO MAKE IT A MORE TOURIST
ATTRACTION IS TO PUT A WINERY ))
>>IN 1988, JACK SANDERS, OWNER
OF SANDERS FAMILY WINERY, FILED
FOR A FEDERAL LICENSE
TO MAKE WINE IN NEVADA.
PAHRUMP VALLEY VINEYARDS WAS
THE FRUTATION OF THAT, BEFORE
SANDER'S SOLD IT IN 2005.
WHILE MANY MAY ONLY KNOW OF THAT
WINERY IN PAHRUMP...
NEW LOCATIONS HAVE STARTED TO
POP UP.
((JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"WE WANTED PEOPLE TO
HAVE A TOUCH OF TUSCANY A TOUCH
OF ITALY AND REALLY NOT HAVE TO
TRAVEL TOO FAR TO VISIT ))
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY HAS AN
AMAZING VIEW OF
MOUNT CHARLESTON---
FROM THE OTHER SIDE THAT WE SEE
IN LAS VEGAS.
((JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO
US IS A PISTACHIO FARM )) ((
JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"YOU'LL ENTER INTO THE
WINERY THROUGH THE COURT YARD TO
OUR AMPITHEATHER WHERE WE
ACTUALLY DO SHOWS ))
>> AND THERE IS SOME HISTORY
TOO.
((JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"THERE'S THE ORIGINAL
WINERY THAT I STARTED IS PAHRUMP
VALLEY WINERY THEN THERE IS
ARTESIAN SELLARS AND THERE IS
STONE WISE MEATERY )) (( JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS
FAMILY WINERY
"WE DO WHITE WINES, WE
DO RED WINES, ROSE WINES ))
EVEN CHAMPAGNE ...
WINE TASTING IS FREE, AND
BOTTLES RANGE
BETWEEN 10 AND 16 DOLLARS.
(( JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"YOU CAN GET THE MOST
PERFECT PHOTO YOU WANTED )) ((
JACK W,
SANDERS-OWNER AND WINE MAKER
SANDERS FAMILY WINERY
"NO MATTER WHERE YOU
ARE IN FRONT OF OUR STATUE AT
THE ENTRANCE WHETHER IT'S THE
ENTRANCE THROUGH THE AMITHEATHER
AND THE WINERY JUST THE BUILDING
ITSELF IS TUSCAN PREVENTIAL ))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>> THE WINERY DOES NOT SELL
FOOD.
YOU CAN BRING YOUR OWN.
PETS ARE ALSO PERMITTED.//
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
NEXT-- ROQUI THEUS TAKES US TO
THE SUMMER SET-UP...
AT THE "BELLAGIO." ((ROQUI
THEUS//ALLOW
ME TO INTRODUCE YOU TO GAYA THE
GODDESS OF EARTH -- SHE HAS
BROUGHT A BEAUTIFUL NEW SUMMER
DISPLAY TO THE BELLAGIO
CONSERVATORY, CELEBRATING OUR
ECO-SYSTEM, I'LL HAVE THE
DETAILS COMING UP.
))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
>>>IT'S THAT TIME AGAIN...
THE BELLAGIO CONSERVATORY HAS
REVEALED ITS NEW SUMMER DISPLAY
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
AND IT'S CELEBRATING OUR
BEAUTIFUL EARTH...
>>> ROQUI THEUS STOPPED BY TO
GIVE US A PREVIEW -
((ROQUI THEUS))
I AM SO HAPPPY TO BE BACK AT THE
BELLAGIO CONERVATORY WHERE WE'RE
SHOWING OFF THE NEW SUMMER
DISPLAY -- I FEEL LIKE IT'S BEEN
AWHILE AND NOW I'M AT TULUM
MEXICO.
IS THAT RIGHT?
ED LIBBY, DESIGNER:
MAYBE TULUM MEXICO, MAYBE
SOMETHING A LITTLE SCANDANAVIAN,
MAYBE RAIN FOREST-Y.
THIS IS CALLED ECO SEASON OF
EARTHLY AWARENESS AND WE REALLY
WANT YOU TO TAKE AWAY WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO TAKE FROM IT.
THIS BED REPRESENTS AIR AND
WIND...
WE HAVE EARTH REPRESENTED HERE,
WATER...
WHICH IS A BELLAGIO
TRADEMARK AND FIRE BEHIND US.
((ROQUI THEUS))
SO WHAT WENT BEHIND DESIGNING
THIS ONE IN PARTICULAR?
WHAT'S NEW?
ED LIBBY, DESIGNER:
SO THIS IS A 90% NEW EXHIBIT.
WE DO HAVE SOME PIECES THAT WE
REPURPOSED FROM OTHER EXHIBITS
WHICH IS KINDA WHAT WE'RE ALL
ABOUT, BUT THIS WAS A YEAR AND A
HALF IN THE MAKING AND WE
ACTUALLY STARTED DESIGNING THIS
QUITE A LONG TIME AGO AND IT'S
EVOLVED AS WE'VE COME ALONG AN
REALLY BECOME SOMETHING VERY
MAGNIFICENT.
((ROQUI THEUS))
IT IS BEAUTIFUL AND YOU
MENTIONED THE SUSTAINABILITTY
AND THAT YOU'RE REPURPOSING
ITEMS HERE SO LET ME MOVE OVER
HERE TO LESLIE TO TALK ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABILITY HERE AT THE
BELLAGIO AND MGM RESORTS.
LESLIE BAECKEROOT,
CONSERVATORY MANAGER:
YES, WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
WELCOME BACK OUR SUSTAINABILITY
INITIATIVE AT MGM RESORTS
INTERNATIONAL AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WE TRY TO USE LIVE
MATERIAL AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TREES AROUND
THE PERIMETER OF THE
CONSERVATORY THAT HAVE BEEN
RESIDENTS FOR FIVE OR MORE YEARS
-- AND SOME SMALLER SHURBS THAT
WE'VE HAD SINCE LAST
SUMMER SO ANY TIME THAT WE CAN
RE-USE OR REPURPOSE THINGS, WE
DO.
IF THINGS ARE NOT UP TO STANDARD
TO REPRUPOSE THEN WE SEPARATE
THEM FROM THEIR POTS AND THEY
GOT OUT TO A COMPOSTING
FACILITY OUT IN NORTH LAS
VEGAS.THEY'RE TURNED IN THE
HEAT AND THEY'RE TURNED INTO
MULCH AND PACKAGED FOR LOCAL
LANDSCAPERS TO PURCHASE.
((ROQUI THEUS))
SEE THAT'S WHY I LOVE COMING TO
TALK TO YOU GUYS -- BESIDES
COMING THROUGH AND WALKING AND
TAKING PHOTOS AND ENJOYING THE
DISPLAY WE GET TO HEAR THE
BEHIND THE SCENES AND TAKE A
REAL DEEPER LOOK -- WHAT DID YOU
CALL IT? UP-CLOSE MAGIC?
ED LIBBY, DESIGNER:
WE CALL IT THE UP-CLOSE MAGIC
AND THE CLOSER YOU GET TO ANY OF
THESE DISPLAYS THE MORE KINDA
INVOLVED AND THE DEEPER THE
GUEST
EXPERIENCE GETS.
((ROQUI THEUS))
IT IS INCREDIBLE -- SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT LESLIE THE FACT THAT
WE ARE NOW IT'S JUNE 1ST -- WE
DON'T HAVE TO WEAR MASKS, NO
SOCIAL DISTANCING, 100%
CAPACITY.
LESLIE BAECKEROOT,
CONSERVATORY MANAGER:
YES, SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
WELCOME EVERYONE BACK, 24 HOURS
A DAY, USING ANY POINT OF ENTRY
THAT THEY CHOOSE TO GET THAT
PERFECT SHOT.
((ROQUI THEUS))
ALRIGHT ED AND LESLIE THANK YOU
GUYS FOR INVITING US DOWN -- YOU
GUYS HAVE TO COME ENJOY THIS...
THROUGH AUGUST, CORRECT?
ED LIBBY, DESIGNER:
AUGUST 28TH
((ROQUI THEUS))
AUGUST 28TH.
IT IS BEAUTIFUL HERE -- I'LL
SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
>>> A NEW EXHIBIT IS NOW OPEN
AT THE BELLAGIO GALLERY OF FINE
ARTS.
"LEATHER THROWERS" WILL
HIGHLIGHT ARTISTS WHO HAVE
UTILIZED IMAGERY AND THE
PERSONALITIES OF BOXING TO
CREATE
SCULPTURES, PAINTINGS AND
DRAWINGS.
SEVERAL LAS VEGAS COLLECTORS
HAVE LOANED THEIR PIECES TO
THE EXHIBIT FOR THE FIRST TIME.
"LEATHER THROWERS" WILL BE ON
DISPALY STARTING FRIDAY UNTIL
AUGUST 22ND AT THE BELLAGIO
GALLERY OF FINE ARTS.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
AND WE CAN'T FORGET-- OF
COURSE THE MOST POPULAR PLACE TO
TAKE A PICTURE..
THE WELCOME TO LAS VEGAS SIGN
IT WAS DESIGNED IN 19-59 AND HAS
DRAWN LARGE CROWDS EVER SINCE.
THE 25-FOOT-TALL WELCOME SIGN
HAS BECOME ONE OF THE CITY'S
MOST ICONIC LANDMARKS AND ONE OF
THE BEST SELFIE SPOTS IN TOWN.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
THANKS FOR WATCHING
DESTINATION VEGAS.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
MAKE SURE TO TAG 8 NEWS NOW IN
ANY
OF YOUR PICTURES AT ANY OF THESE
LOCATIONS.
GOOD NIGHT